nous avons perdu notre vie
notre sécurité
nous pouvons obtenir ce plan n'importe quel avenir parce que
nous ne savons pas ce que sera demain
et c'est très stressant
maintenant qu'ils peuvent emmener
[Music]
à l'étranger
cette semaine nous avons eu
des nouvelles d'une fille fille ukrainienne  92
ans qui a été violée par un homme polonais à qui
il l'a invitée pour héberger sa
maison et l'aider à
traverser cette situation culturelle
et malheureusement c'est arrivé
[Musique] [
Musique]
nous devons
vraiment nous tenir debout et aussi leur parler et
de leurs droits  et d'une manière ou d'une autre, essayant de
les protéger et de
les sensibiliser à ce qui peut arriver et comment
peuvent-ils faire face à une telle situation, n'est-ce pas?